NEW SCENES OF ANARCHY AND
LIBERAL CITIES AS CRIMINALS GET
A FREE PASS TO BEAT UP COPS.
A 16-YEAR-OLD AFTER THIS NASTY
BRAWL WITH AN NYPD OFFICER
INSIDE A SUBWAY STATION AFTER
BEING STOPPED FOR NOT PAYING THE
FAIR.
THE TEAM REPEATEDLY PUNCHING THE
OFFICER OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEN WRESTLING HIM TO THE GROUND
INCLUDING THE OFFICER IN A CHOKE
HOLD.
THAT SUSPECT WAS LATER CHARGED
WITH ASSAULT AND RESISTING
ARREST, BUT YOU CAN PROBABLY
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
JUST HOURS LATER HE WAS BACK OUT
ON THE STREET AND THAT IS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE TEEN
HAS BEEN BUSTED TWICE BEFORE FOR
ROBBERY AND GUN POSSESSION.
A FORMER COP TELLING JESSE THIS
IS THE DIRECT RESULT OF THE LEFT
CONSTANT ANTI-POLICE RHETORIC.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THIS COP
FELT SO IN FEAR OF HIS LIFE THAT
HE HAD TO USE THAT WEAPON, THERE
WILL BE RIOTS, HE HAS TO WORRY
ABOUT GETTING ARRESTED IN LOSING
HIS JOB AND GETTING SUED
CIVILLY.
SO WHILE THEY ARE CONCENTRATING
ON THAT, THEY VERY WELL MAY LOSE
THEIR LIVES.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS REACTING AND
BLAMING RIDICULOUS NO CASH BAIL
LAWS.
>> CATCH, RELEASE, REPEAT.
CATCH, RELEASE, REPEAT.
THIS PERSON WAS ARRESTED FOR
ROBBERY A FEW DAYS AGO.
NOW HE IS BACK AS SOON A SUITE
CATCH THEM, THE SYSTEM RELEASES
THEM AND THEY REPEAT THE ACTION.
THAT IS JUST --
WHEN I SAY THAT WE ARE THE
LAUGHINGSTOCK OF THE COUNTRY,
THIS IS WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT.
HOW DO WE KEEP OUR CITY SAFE
WHEN THE OTHER